hey this is preshtalwalker
a few years ago i read a great
introduction to probability titled
understanding probability by professor
hank times
this was not for school or for work i
just read probability textbooks in my
spare time for fun
so anyway i was absolutely surprised and
thrilled when i got an email from hank
times who said he was a fan of mind your
decisions
furthermore he suggested a couple of
problems from his new book probability a
lively introduction
people always email me asking how to
learn about probability so here are two
books i can recommend
do check them out
the puzzle in this video is adapted from
probability a lively introduction
your birthday cake has n burning candles
and you need to blow out all the candles
before anyone can eat cake
each time you try to blow out the
candles the number of candles that
remain burning is a random event
if the cake starts with k-burning
candles
then after your attempt to blow them out
it will end up with a whole number of
burning candles between zero and k minus
one
and each possibility occurs with equal
chance
in other words each time you will blow
out at least one candle and for k larger
than one you will blow a random number
of candles between one and k
what is the expected number of times you
must blow out the candles until all of
the end candles are blown out and
everyone can eat cake
can you figure this problem out
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so one way to solve this problem is by
considering smaller values and setting
up a recursive equation
let's write e k to be the expected
number when there are k burning candles
on the cake
if the cake has zero burning candles
then we're done
e zero equals zero
for a cake with one burning candle we
are sure to blow it out in one attempt
e1 equals one
what about a cake with two burning
candles what is e2
so after one attempt we have a couple of
possibilities
with probability one-half
we blow out both candles so we are done
e0 equals zero
but with probability one-half one candle
still burns
and we expect e1 which equals one more
attempts to blow out all of the candles
we can combine these into a simple
equation
e2 equals one
plus
one half times the quantity e0 plus e1
we can substitute in the values for e0
and e1 and we get e2 is equal to three
halves
now i tried working out e3 and e4 and
several more values but i wasn't able to
see any particular pattern
but when you're stuck don't give up
i thought about how to solve this
recurrence equation and i eventually
found a tip
sometimes you can solve these by
subtracting consecutive terms
so that ended up working out for me and
i will explain that strategy next
so i generalized this recurrence
equation what if a cake has k plus one
burning candles
we will use one attempt for sure and
then we will be left with k plus one
equally likely outcomes
the number of candles still burning will
be a number from zero to k
associated with additional expected
attempts of e0 e1 e2 all the way to ek
respectively depending on the number of
candles still burning
we can write this in one equation
e of k plus one equals one for the one
attempt plus
it will be the average of these k plus
one
possible outcomes
so we have one over k plus one
times
e zero plus e one plus all the way going
to e k
now we'll multiply both sides of the
equation by k plus one
so we have k plus one times e of k plus
one
and that will be equal to k plus one
plus the sum going from e 0 to e k
now to get consecutive terms we'll
consider the previous term
we'll decrease each index by 1
to consider a cake with k candles
so on the left hand side
this will be k times e k
then we consider this k plus 1 term
that'll become k
then we consider the sum from 0 to k
that'll become the sum from 0 to k minus
1.
so this is the equation for birthday
cake with k candles
so write this equation out and now we'll
consider these two equations
notice there are a lot of similar terms
in these equations
so we can simplify this by subtracting
the second equation from the first we
can cancel many of these terms
on the right hand side the k's will
cancel
e0 will cancel e1 will cancel all the
way going up to e of k minus 1.
when we do the subtraction we have k
plus 1
times e of k plus 1
minus k times e k
and that equals 1 plus e k
now we simplify this equation
and then we solve for the difference of
the two terms and we get the difference
e k plus one minus e k is equal to one
over the quantity k plus one
now i understood what this meant
here's the pattern to get to the next
term in the sequence we add the fraction
one over the next term so to get to the
term k plus one we add one over k plus
one
in other words this is the harmonic
series and i could then write out the
explicit form for the pattern going up
to n
e of n equals one plus one half plus one
third plus one fourth all the way to one
over n
as an interesting tidbit since the sum
of the harmonic series diverges the
expected value grows indefinitely
en goes to infinity as n goes to
infinity
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic or a puzzle you can email me
presh mindyourdecisions.com
and you can catch me on social media
either at mindyourdecisions or at presh
talwalkar